what's the relationship
between this uh no conscription and
people standing up to fight for ideas
and the Second Amendment a world
regulatory militia being necessary to
the security of a free state the right
of the people to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed
we're in Texas yeah yes so what's the
role of that uh in in this story the
American population is already armed
before the war
and so even though the union and the
Confederate armies will manufacture and
purchase arms it is already an armed
population so uh the American
presumption going into the war is that
citizens will not be forced to serve but
they will serve in militias to protect
their own property and so the Second
Amendment the key part of the Second
Amendment for me as a historian is the
well-regulated militia part the
presumption that citizens as part of
their civic duty do not have a duty to
join a national Army Prussian style but
are supposed to be involved in defending
their communities
uh and that's that's the reality it's
also a bit of a myth
um and so Americans have have throughout
their history been gun owners
not AK-47 owners but gun owners and gun
ownership has been for the purpose of
community self-defense the question
coming out of that is what does that
mean in terms of do you have access to
everything uh Antonin Scalia even
himself asked this question on the
Supreme Court you know he said in one of
the gun gun cases uh you have the right
to defend yourself but you don't have
the right to own an Uzi
yeah you don't have the right to have a
tank I don't think they'd let you park a
tank Lex in your parking spot right I
looked into this I think I think there's
a gray area around tanks actually
I think you're legit allowed to own a
tank oh you really I think that like
somebody look into somebody told me but
I could see like that because it's very
difficult for that to get out of hand
right right okay there may be one guy in
a tank that you could be breaking laws
in terms of the width of the vehicle
that you're using to operate
um anyway that's that's a hilarious
discussion but starting to make the case
speaking of AK-47s and rifles and back
to Ukraine for a second one of the
fascinating social experiments that
happened in Ukraine at the beginning of
the war is they handed out guns to
everybody rifles and crime went down
which I think is really interesting
yeah
I hope somebody does a kind of
psychological data collection analysis
effort here to try to understand why
because it's not obvious to me that in a
time of War if you give guns to the
entire populace anyone who wants a gun
it's not going to especially in a
country who has historically suffered
from corruption not result in robberies
and assaults and all that kind of stuff
there's a deep lesson there now I don't
know if you can extend that lesson
Beyond wartime though right that's the
question what happens after the war I
mean my inclination would be to say that
can work during war but you have to take
the guns back after the war
but they might be very upset when you
try that's the problem no that's
precisely the problem that that's
actually part of the story here I mean
what happens after the Civil War after
Appomattox in 1865 is that many uh
Southern soldiers go home with their
guns and they misuse their weapons uh to
quite frankly shoot and intimidate uh
former slaves who are now citizens this
is a big problem I talk about this in
the book in Memphis in 1866 it is former
Confederate soldiers and police officers
and judges who are responsible for
hundreds of rapes uh within a two-day
period and destroying an entire
community of African Americans and
they're able to do that because they
brought their guns home but underneath
underneath the issue of guns there is
just the fundamental issue of
hatred and inability to see uh other
humans in this in this world as having
equal value as another human being